بولندا بغضب اذا حاول الاوكران اغراقنا
معهم فسنرفع ايدينا ونتركهم يواجهون
مصيرهم
يطالب بالغاء الفيتو الروسي فهل تقبل
الامم المتحده ردا على زيارتكم لروسيا
كوريا الجنوبيه تفتح مخازنها للاوكران
اوروبا بمساعده روسيا وموسكو هناك تدخلات
لحلف الناتو قد تقودنا لمواجهات مباشره
بينما تتعرض روسيا لهجوم مجهول في السودان
والجيش الاثري يخطف مواقع الارمن بسرعه
فائقه والروس يتدخلون ويدفعون الثمن
واردوغنوا في لقاء واحد والعين ترمق
السعوديه بينما تبحث واشنطن عن اتفاق امني
لخطب ود الرياض على طريقه اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه وطوكيو تفاجئ الجميع بخطوه نحو
كوريا الشماليه والجزائر تصرخ وجه العالم
ان نتخلى عن فلسطين
الغريق يتمسك بقشه
المصلحه الشخصيه قبل كل شيء حتى وان ذابت
اوكرانيا في غايه بالجب فكل دوله في
العالم وفي الغرب خصوصا تبحث عن مصالحها
وها هو الرئيس البولندي دوده يعلنها اذا
اضر الغريق بنا واغرقنا معه لن يحصل على
المساعده ويقصد اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان
وارسو يجب ان تحمي مصالحها وشبه دودكييف
بالشخص الغريق الذي يتخبط فاذا حاول احد
المساعده فغالب الظن انهما سيغرقان معا
وكما يقولها اليمنيون من صلي الا اطالب
مغفره اي لا شيء بالمجان وهو ما صرح به
دوده في العلم الرد الاوكراني لم يتاخر
وعلى لسان الرئيس زلينسكي الذي اتهم الدول
الاوروبيه التي لم ترفع الحظر عن استيراد
المنتجات الزراعيه الاوكرانيا بانها تساعد
روسيا هل نسي زلينسكي جميع مساعدات تلك
الدول وبدا يطلق سهامه يمنه ويسرا ولسان
حاله تلك الدول يقول هو كما يقولونها
المصريون فيما اعاد الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بعضا من بريق الامر للاوكران وذلك
في كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده حيث قال ان روسيا تتحمل مسؤوليه
الحرب في اوكرانيا وهي قادره على انهائها
مشيرا الى ان الولايات المتحده ستواصل دعم
اوكرانيا ولن تقبل استمرار الحرب ضدها دون
محاسبه بدوره عاد الرئيس الاوكراني ليضيف
ان الهجوم المضاده لبلاده يسير بشكل
ايجابي وسيستمر معتبرا انه لا يمكن الجزم
بان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد سيحقق
اختراقا ميدانيا كبيرا هذا العام وكما
نعلم فكوريا الجنوبيه وجارتها الش عدو
تاني لدودتان ونكايه بزياره الاخيره الى
روسيا هي كوريا الجنوبيه تعلن عن فتح
مخازنها لاوكرانيا حيث اعلنت انها ستسلم
اوكرانيا قريبا دفعه اولى من الدبابات
الهندسيه
والتي تم تصنيعها على منصه دبابه
اساسيه في الجيش الكوري الجنوبي لكن موسكو
تجاهلت كوريا الجنوبيه لتاتي برد اكبر
لحلف باكمله حيث اكد نائب وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه ان مناورات النيت عام 2024 جزء من
استعداد لصدام عسكري مباشر مع روسيا وخطوه
اخرى لزعزعه الاستقرار في اوروبا فهل وصلت
الرساله لننتقل الى ميدان المعارك
الاوكرانيه حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه القضاء على اكثر من 500 جندي
اوكراني طائره من نوع 24 و اثنتين واربعين
مسيره خلال يوم هذا واسقطت بطاريات بانسر
الروسيه للدفاع الجوي اربعه صواريخ شبحيه
بريطانيه من طراز ستوم شادو اطلقت قوتك
على القرم الروسيه واليكم المصدر كالعاده
وهو ما نتصفحه امامكم في الموقع الرسمي
للحكومه الروسيه وفي الجانب الاوكراني قال
حاكم منطقه بولتافا وسط اوكرانيا ان
القوات الروسيه استهدفت مصفاه نفط
بالطائرات المسيره ما تسبب في اندلاع حريق
في وقت اعلن فيه الجيش الاوكراني اسقاط
سبع عشره طائره مسيره روسيه من اصل 24
خلال 24 ساعه وها هو المصدر يتحدث
في اوكرانيا ان روسيا شنت هجوما على مصفاه
نفط تقري بطائره مسيره ادى الى نشوب حريق
الى ذلك قال الجيش الاوكراني ان دفاعاته
الجويه اسقطت سبعه عشره مسيره روسيه من
اصل 24
قالت الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه لاقليم
خرسون ان القوات الروسيه نفذت هجمات اطلقت
خلالها مئات القضاء في الصاروخيه سقط اكثر
من عشرين من هات مدينه خرسون وحدها مما
تسبب بوقوع اضرار في المدينه وكانت
الاداره العسكريه لمقاطعه البيف اعلنت ان
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت خمسه عشره مسيره من
اصل 18 اغارت على المنطقه لتنتقل الحرب
بين كييف وبوسكو الى افريقيا هذه المره
والى السودان تحديدا حيث ذكر تقرير لشبكه
سي ان الامريكيه انه من المحتمل ان تكون
اوكرانيا قد استهدفت مواقع لقوات الدعم
السريع في السودان التي انها تلقى الدعما
من مجموعه فاقنر العسكريه الروسيه في
صراعها الذي تخوض مع الجيش السوداني منذ
ابريل الماضي واوضحت الشبكه ان القوات
الخاصه الاوكرانيه على الارجح نفذت هجمات
بطائرات مسيره مستهدفه عناصر مدعومه من
قرب العاصمه السودانيه ما يشير الى توسع
نطاق الحرب الاوكرانيه يا ساده ومن
افريقيا تعود الحرب في الجوار الروسي
والاوكراني وبعد عمليه عسكريه خاطفه من
الجيش الاذري حيث كانت وزاره الدفاع
الاثريه قد اوضحت ان جيشها سيطر على اكثر
من 90 موقعا عسكريا ارمنيا فيما كان مسؤول
كبير سابق في اداره كارباخ التابعه لعرقيه
الارمن قد قال انما يقرب من مئه شخص قتلوا
واصيب مئات اخرون في المنطقه الانفصاليه
بعد ان بدات اذربيجان وصفها بانها حرب
كبيره نزح بسببها حوالي
عن اقليم جرابات بينما كان الرئيس الاذري
الهام علي افقد اكد ان تسليم القوات
الارمنيه اسلحه
اساسي لوقف باكو عمليه العسكريه ولكن
سرعان منطفات شراره الحرب هذه بتدخل روسي
ليتوصل طرف النزاع في جرباخ اذربيجان
وسلطات الاقليم غير المعترف بها الى اتفاق
لوقف اطلاق النار باشراف من قياده قوات
حفظ السلام الروسيه لكن لابد من تضحيات من
اجل السلام حيث افادت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه بمقتل عدد من الجنود الروس في
وحده حفظ السلام باطلاق نار في منطقه
جانيتاج في غاباغ فلنتات الحرب بعد هذا
كله وبهذه السرعه ام انها مجرد استراحه
للمحاربين الاحداث والتطورات من دون شروط
مسبقه اليابان متفاجئ العلم بخطوه نحو
كوريا الشماليه حيث اعلن رئيس الياباني في
كلمه بالامم المتحده عن رغبته في تطبيع
العلاقات مع كوريا الشماليه وتصميمه على
لقاء الزعيم بهدف فتح صفحه جديده سويا
والى تركيا التقى الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان لاول مره مع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
على هامش اجتماعات الامم المتحده في
نيويورك وبحث قضايا مهمه بينها عمليه
التطبيع بين اسرائيل والسعوديه وعلى ذكر
السعوديه ذكرت صحيفه ان الولايات المتحده
تبحث مع السعوديه شروط معاهده دفاع مشترك
شبيهه بالاتفاقيه العسكريه مع اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه واوضحت الصحيفه ان اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن تسعى من خلال
هذه الاتفاقيه لدفع السعوديه الى تطبيع
العلاقات مع اسرائيل والى الجزائر اكد
الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون خلال
كلمه له امام الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده ان الجزائر لن تتخلى عن مسانده
القضايا العادله وعلى راسها القضيه
الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]